LINEUP, STILL WITHOUT JAMIE
OLEKSIAK.
HAYDN FLEURY WILL STEP IN ON THE
BACK END AND
HELD IN AT
PICKPOCKETED. USE THE
BUMP TORE BREAK SOME OF ST.
LOUIS' PRESSURE.
>> John: YOU CAN SEE THE TIMESC.
TYLER BOZAK.
IT IS A SHORT-HANDED GOAL AND
ST. LOUIS BREAKS THE SEAL. AND
NET.
THAT IS NOT WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING
FOR.
YOU WANT THE OFOF BY
BOZAK.
MARCO SCANDELLA HAD THE
>> J.T.: THAT IS A G17.
BROUGHT IN BY TARASENKO TO THE
LINE.
OUT IN FRONT.
TIPPED.
NO, THEY SCORE ON THE FOLLOW UP.
BRAYDEN SCHENN GETS  NET FOR
SCHENN ALL ALONE ON THE
BACKDOOR.
>>>> John: THE TIP BY RYAN
O'REILLY, THEHEAVE IT AWAY TO R
THOMAS.
HERE COME THE BLUES.
KYROU WITH A   MIKKOLA HAD IT
AND LOST IT.
JOONAS
>> J.T.: GEEKIE WITH A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY.
GOOD CROSS-ICE PASS F TOP.
GEEKIE COLLECTS IT.
TWOSAAD.
FAULK GETS IT BACK.
UICK MOVE AND
HE IS ABLE TO KEEP THAT PLINE.
O'REILLY.
HERE IS PERRON.
OUT HERE.
FULL EXTENSION.
>> ABLE TO
JOONAS DONSKOI.
THEY GAIN THE ZONE.
DONSKOIPARAYKO, A SHOT KICKED O.
HERE COME THE KRAKEN.
MASON APPLETON ON CORNER, YANNI.
RILEY SHEAHAN GETS IT OUT.
BLACTARASENKO, JARED McCANN TO
SCORE.
PA RIGHT ON TO
BUCHNEVICH'S STICK.
DOES NOT WAS TO CENTER.
GOURDE.
A TOUGHRLE CYCLES HIGH,
PICKPOCKETED BY PARAYKO.
HERE HE COMES.
PARAYKO DELAYS AND
SLIGHT DRAG.
IT IS A GOOD LOOK.
YOU DON'T KNOW IF HE
KYROU.
HE SCORES.
JORDAN KYROU STUFFS IT HOME. TO
PAST.
>> John: BAD COVERAGE ON THE IT
JOHANSSON.
ALL THE WAY ACROSS, FLEURY,